nancy pelosi's arrived in taiwan despite
china warning of serious consequences if
she visited the island beijing said the
visit would undermine its sovereignty
and security interests the island nation
is self-ruled but china claims it as its
own we just witnessed those arrival
pictures momentary moments ago and joe
pike joins me now to react but joe i
just want to also mention we're getting
some flashes of some of the headlines
coming from nancy
pelosi she says america's solidarity
with the people of taiwan is more
important today than ever she says our
discussion with taiwan leadership will
focus on reaffirming our support for our
partner and on promoting our shared
interest including advancing a free and
open indo-pacific region she says this
visit in no way contradicts
long-standing united states policy but
that one line of uh
referring to taiwan as our partner
will certainly muddy the waters because
the u.s was meant to have a totally
ambiguous
position when it came to taipei and
no doubt these sorts of comments the
arrival itself will not help
china's reaction
not at all and they warned yesterday
wilfred of consequences if this trip
were to go ahead the highest level uh
u.s visit to taiwan for 25 years since
newt gingrich a previous house speaker
in 1997
and
the chinese have kept to their word in
terms of consequences we have
seen
fighter jets
chinese fighter jets flying close to the
median line that dividing line the
taiwan strike we've seen army units put
on high alert and we've also heard
in the last hour or so from the chinese
foreign ministry with a pretty strong
message
made the us and taiwan have colluded to
make provocations first and china has
only been compelled to act out of
self-defense in the face of the us's
unscrupulous behavior in defiance of
china's repeated and serious complaints
any counter measures china is taking
will be justified and necessary it is
also the right of all independent and
sovereign states
this will be justified and necessary
what does that mean will there be
counter measures beyond what we've
already seen in terms of these fighter
jets and army units uh put
on high alert certainly the real concern
of the
white house and of the pentagon of the
national security council here in
washington dc
is that
the chinese could change their position
on military aid for the russians
in the conflict in ukraine so far xi
jinping has not we understand
sent any military support to help
vladimir putin and the russians of
course president putin would be very
keen to get his hands on china's very
high-tech drones the involvement of the
chinese could of course completely
change the balance of power in that
conflict and therefore i think the
concern in the white house is that this
visit from nancy pelosi this arrival
you're seeing here
in the airport in the capital taipei
could anger the chinese so much they
changed their position on the issue of
ukraine
certainly this is not a brief visit the
fact that she's visiting late at night
means she's staying overnight newt
gingrich 25 years ago only stopped for a
number of hours but it's also important
i think to point out wilfred that nancy
pelosi's views on china her hawkishness
on china her belief in international
human rights as she would see it is
entirely consistent she's been
consistent and has strong views on this
in her decades-long career on issues
like taiwan on hong kong
on tibet on the uyga genocide
more recently and as she reaches the end
of that career she's 82 years old
unlikely to be the speaker long after
november's midterms i think she knows
the power and significance
of this visit but also that it's
effectively really one of her final
chances to make a big splash
and a big
uh make significant headlines on the
international stage
i'll read out the uh statement uh from
nancy pelosi uh in full we brought some
of the brief headlines from a moment ago
but i'll just read it out in full uh she
says our congressional delegation's
visit to taiwan honors america's
unwavering commitment to supporting
taiwan's vibrant democracy our visit is
part of our broader trip to the
indo-pacific including singapore
malaysia south korea and japan
focused on mutual security economic
partnership and democratic governance
our discussions with taiwan leadership
will focus on reaffirming our support
for our partner and on promoting our
shared interests including advancing a
free and open indo-pacific region
america's solidarity with the 23 million
people of taiwan is more important today
than ever as the world faces a choice
between autocracy and democracy
our visit is one of several
congressional delegations to taiwan and
in no way contradicts long-standing
united states policy guided by the
taiwan relations act of 1979 u.s china
joint communi communiques and the six
assurances the united states continues
to oppose unilateral efforts to change
the status quo that's the end of her
statement and
there's just contradictions in it or
certainly contradictions as far as the
chinese will interpret things joe
because they can say it no way changes
the policy um but refers very clearly to
the democracy of of taiwan which is
perhaps the worst word you can throw in
the chinese eyes
it certainly is yes a statement full of
different contradictions the
contradictions wilfred that nancy pelosi
is
entirely aware of of course she's got to
point out that the u.s government's
diplomatic approach hasn't changed even
if as she knows this visit is
provocative very provocative it's been a
big win i think for the
taiwanese administration because it
gives a signal to other countries across
the world that they may be able to
normalize relationships a little bit
more maybe these visits could become a
little more common that is something the
chinese government are very keen to
avoid they see
taiwan this self-governing island as a
breakaway province and a breakaway
province that at some stage they want to
rejoin
officially
their nation nancy pelosi's trip is very
controversial it's very provocative it's
something that many in the white house
privately warned against but she knows
the impact
of this visit she's aware it's
provocative and i think she'll be
pretty pleased perhaps with
the headline she's already created as
long as it doesn't provoke such serious
consequences
that it changes the relationship between
the us and china longer term to
potentially
change chinese involvement in the war in
ukraine that would really make this
visit look like a massive mistake for
nancy pelosi so it's a risky uh endeavor
but hopefully in the next 40 48 hours or
so
she'll get to a position where she
believes it
kind of paid off it is a risky strategy